muy buenos días Ángela fue el primer
cambio en el senado de la noche y eso
que se esperaba que tardásemos más en
conocer los resultados pero con el 93%
de los votos ya contados feterman aquí
se proclama ganador con un 50,2% seguido
del doctor Oz con un
47,4%. resultados muy ajustados parece
que los demócratas han conseguido
arrebatarles escaño en el senado con una
campaña en la que han invertido más de
100 millones de dólares parece también
que ha tenido mucho que ver ese enfado
por la decisión de la Corte Suprema de
limitar los derechos del derecho al
aborto y tampoco ha ayudado pues la
estrategia que ha seguido el republicano
el doctor Oz de burlarse de su
contrincante por ese derrame cerebral
que sufrió en mayo o de ir a por los
votantes que están descontentos
políticamente o apostar también por ese
aumento de la criminalidad y decir que
afeterman que es vicegobernador de tenía
mano blanda dicen los expertos mano
blanda persiguiendo el crimen dicen los
expertos y aquí seguramente habrá tenido
mucho que ver ese voto de los indecisos
Quién es federman eh quien Ah alzado la
voz con la victoria
sí Ángela aquí todos dicen que se trata
de un político peculiar dice gobernador
del estado de Pensilvania desde el 2019
dicen eso de él porque ya habéis visto
que toda la campaña incluso ayer por la
noche ha vestido en chándal y su
discurso también es atípico de hecho un
dato curioso es que renunció a la casa
la mansión de la vicegobernación y lado
no para que los niños pudiesen tener una
piscina en 2015 fue declarado alcalde de
Prado que es una pequeña localidad donde
él vive y allí pues ha apostado mucho
por las clases más desfavorecidas por
ayudar a generar trabajo para los
jóvenes junto con su mujer han peleado
por las causas en las que creen como es
la inmigración o el matrimonio entre
personas del mismo sexo y están además
muy arropados por la comunidad
afroamericana que representa un 80% de
la ciudad de donde es Alcalde que
recordemos que se trata de un grupo
minoritario que tenía mucho peso en
estas elecciones y que podría inclinar
La balanza hacia un lado otro puede que
ellos también hayan tenido mucho que ver
en esta Victoria